hey guys it is Friday which means I go
five of this week's biggest stories all
ready to go for you and I warn you now a
lot of them are about four
it seems a lot of us have wasteland on
the brain lately and that may have
attributed to the fact that fallout 4
now stands as the most played game on
Steam right now at the time of writing
fallout 4 has more concurrent steam
players than any other game including
dota 2 and counter strike global
offensive which are traditional
frontrunners while fallout 4 still has a
ways to go to match the all-time high
concurrent peaks of dota 2 and CS co
which stand at 1.2 million and 800,000
respectively it's a pretty awesome show
of the RPGs current popularity on these
days can you xbox one experience patch
landed yesterday and Microsoft reckon
it's the biggest update anyone's ever
made for a console those of you with
Xbox one's might not be looking forward
to the one gigabyte download but it
should be well worth it the update is
introducing a UI overhaul backwards
compatibility support for selected xbox
360 games and it will make Windows 10
the consoles underlying OS Microsoft is
promising that improved intuitive pneus
and speed up priorities in the updates
with some functions now running up to 10
times faster
it has to have come out to explain how
fallout 4 mods are going to work on the
ps4 and Xbox one the fallout 4 creation
kit which helps PC players make mods for
the RPG will launch in early 2016 whilst
the bordered mods will arrive on xbox
one sometime later and ps4 sometime
after that on the issue of how mods will
work on consoles marketing exec Pete
Hines explained we want it to be a
really streamlined fun experience
there's still specifics that we have to
work out it's part of our post launch
plan of course even though flirt for
doesn't officially support mods yet
we're already seeing some mods arrive on
PC next up a release date and some
information on the collector's editions
of Dark Souls 3 late this week DK games
published listings for two versions of
Dark Souls 3 the collector edition and
the prestige edition accompanying each
of these images was the contents of each
edition as well as a release date of
April 12 2016 the collector edition
includes the game a 25 centimeter red
Knight figurine and art book and cloth
maps soundtrack iron-on patches metal
case and collector's box comparatively
the prestige edition includes almost all
of those items although you get a 40
centimeter lord of cinder figurine
instead of the smaller statue and a
different collection box the price of
the list of in united arab emirates
dirham so they're unlikely to match up
to us prices as they stand currently
which equals out to about 136 USD for
the collector edition and 490 us bucks
for the prestige edition
finally it's not been all sunshine and
roses for the launch of Fallout 4 as
there have been reports of bugs poor
console performance and cancellations of
pre-orders UK retailer game has been in
hot water with fallout fans as it
appears game mistakenly cancelled
numerous pre-orders of the ultra rare
pip-boy addition the retailer claimed a
payment error is to blame for the many
pre-audit issues but consumers are
doubtful that this is the root of the
problem a similar slew of pre order
cancellations occurred from game when
metal gear solid 5 landed in August and
the retailer throughout the same line of
blaming the banks and PayPal the
retailer are insisting that they're
holding all pre-orders and getting in
touch with each customer individually
although according to those missing
their orders this is not going as
smoothly as game are insinuating let me
know down in that comment section what
you cared about this week and what
you'll be playing this weekend this week
on site we announced our October game of
the month I tell you about weird ways to
play your favorite games on the gist and
Lucy gives you the lowdown on rise of
the Tomb Raider that is everything I
have you this week but as always have
yourself an awesome weekend as I will
catch you again on Monday
you